ja herr dr montgomery wie ist die lage
gut ich habe aber gehört dass die
schweinegrippe betrifft die fälle
steigen gerade in den letzten tagen
dramatisch an ich glaube robert koch
institut hat am 19 11 30.000 gemeldet
gestern elfter elfter 50.000 wie geht es
weiter bezogen auf die schweinegrippe
ist die lage genauso wie vorhergesehen
man hat ja schon immer als die erste
welle kamen gesagt es wird eine zweite
welle geben die ist jetzt da wir sind
gerüstet wir haben die chance für die
bevölkerung sich impfen zu lassen
ob der impfstoff jetzt gleich in
ausreichender menge zur verfügung stellt
das ist fraglich aber wer sich impfen
lassen will kann sich in den nächsten
wochen impfen lassen das ist die beste
voraussetzung um dieser attacke eines
virus sozusagen die spitze zu brechen es
ist die größte impfaktion in der
geschichte deutschlands sowas hat es
noch nicht gegeben aber es ist ein
bisschen chaotischen sie nicht alle sind
sich einig es gibt ärzte die glaube ich
nicht impfen wollen die sagen der
impfstoff ist eigentlich zu stark dafür
weil da gibt es ja auch diskussionen was
ist das neben stoff da gibt es ein
verstärker drin der umstritten ist und
es gibt landstriche die nicht versorgt
sind es gibt zu wenig impfstoff in
teilen in köln gibt es jetzt glaube ich
ist es ausgegangen jetzt muss man wieder
warten also hat man damit nicht
gerechnet oder wo ist wo liegen die
probleme also die probleme liegen darin
dass wir auch mit einer neuen situation
konfrontiert sind wir haben zum ersten
mal die chance bei einem völlig neuen
virus innerhalb der kurzen zeit die uns
das virus gelassenheit von wenigen
monaten eine total impfung der
bevölkerung durchzuführen wenn die
bevölkerung mit macht das ist etwas was
es in der weise nie gegeben hat das feld
auch ein bisschen er in den rahmen von
katastrophenschutz als von normaler
medizinischer versorgung und ich bin
sicher wenn wir in die details der
wissenschaftlichen argumenten ihnen wird
auch diese sendung am ende mehr zu einer
verunsicherung beitragen weil auch ich
kann ja nichts anderes sagen als dieser
impfstoff ist nicht an sehr vielen
menschen getestet sondern an weniger als
früher trotzdem habe ich mich impfen
lassen weil ich von dem konzept dieses
impfstoffes an sich überzeugt wir waren
bei ihnen die nebenwirkungen gar keine
ich habe die die einstichstelle
natürlich gespürt und sind männer jahres
spritzen an geht sowieso immer etwas
zurückhaltend und ich habe also einen
tag lang gemerkt dass da in meinem
oberarm spritze gesetzt worden war ich
habe keinerlei nebenwirkungen verspürt
ich habe aber bei anderen kollegen
welche gesehen wir rechnen in etwa zehn
prozent der fälle von sogenannten
nördlichen reaktionen also dass der
anblick wird dass es ein bisschen rot
wird dass es eigentlich importen
unangenehmes im muskel und erde vorbei
einem prozent auch durchaus allgemein
symptome dass man mal ein tag richtig
natürlich ist das auch fieber gibt aber
das sind im grunde genommen wenn sie
mich mal so als arzt fragen sind das
kleinigkeiten gegenüber dem risiko an
der schweinegrippe wenn auch nur selten
so doch zu sterben sie sind für die
impfung was ist denn für sie das
wichtigste argument für diese impfung
das wichtigste argument für die impfung
ist dass wir durch die schweinegrippe
impfung bei einer letalität von etwa 0 0
0 7% letalität todesrate von einer einer
sterberate durch die infektion wenn man
infiziert ist von 0,007 prozent
gleichwohl immer noch für große teile
der bevölkerung infiziert werden davon
ausgehen müssen dass etwa 5000 menschen
in der bundesrepublik sterben ich als
arzt sehe die krisen chance das zu
verhindern denn an der impfung ist
bisher noch niemand gestorben ich will
ja nicht verhehlen dass es auch länder
gibt die diesen stoff durchaus
kritischer sehen die schweiz zum
beispiel hat den impfstoff
lediglich für menschen zwischen 17 und
65 zugelassen und hat kleinere kinder
ältere menschen und schwangere frauen
ausgeschlossen von der verwendung
mit pandemrix das muss man fairerweise
einfach sagen andererseits gibt es
länder wie zum beispiel belgien da ist
inzwischen die gesamte bevölkerung durch
geimpft ohne dass man eine einzige
nebenwirkung besonderer art bemerkt
hätte es gibt inzwischen ja in
deutschland in eine in europa muss man
sagen über eine millionen angewandte
pandemrix dosen und es gibt nicht eine
einzige berichtete uns erstaunen de
schwerwiegende komplikationen also man
kann es mit der mit der risiko
gläubigkeit der menschen auch
übertreiben und vor allem wird es immer
wieder bewusst genutzt und den menschen
angst zu machen wir haben ja glück dass
wir an einem so relativ harmlosen virus
wie dem schweinegrippe virus einmal
unsere gesamte katastrophen planung für
den pandemiefall üben können ich hoffe
dass es uns gelingt im nächsten jahr all
diese argumente nochmals zu sammeln sie
auch alle noch sauber zu erinnern dass
vielleicht sich dann auch alle noch an
das erinnern was sie mal gesagt haben um
dann zu lernen wie wir es das nächste
mal besser machen könnte da gibt es eine
ganze menge was man verbessern kann dann
schließt sich natürlich die frage wann
ist denn diese übung überhaupt nötig
also ist es überhaupt versucht haben
diese erkrankung war das ist ja dann das
gegenargument nötig diese große übung zu
machen also ich warne davor die
schweinegrippe in ihrer gefährlichkeit
jetzt ganz klein zu reden erstens bitte
erinnern sie sich daran was ihr für
meldungen im mai juni über die
weltgesundheitsorganisation aus mexiko
und den amt in amerika sage ich mal süd
und nord amerika bekommen haben damals
hatten wir alle richtig schiss dass das
eine sogar die so lungen solche jahres
weit über steigende gefährliche
erkrankung sei die da auf uns zukam und
die regierung entstanden vor dem dilemma
dass sie im mai/juni sich entscheiden
mussten impfstoff zu kaufen der weltweit
limitiert war weltweit kann man nur 4,2
milliarden dosen dieses impfstoffes
herstellen und die pharmaindustrie hat
das getan was man den wettbewerb system
dann tut sie an ihrer haut teuer zu
markte getan und sie hatten mit den
regierungen gehandelt und die
bundesregierung stand etwa im mai/juni
einfach vor der fast erpresserischen
aussage entweder er unterschreibt jetzt
einen vertrag und kauft oder andere
stehen da und sind bereit zu kaufen und
ihr könnt am ende sehen was übrig bleibt
so ist es einigen staaten ergangen polen
hat bis heute nicht einen einzigen
tropfen impfstoff verkaufen können als
land insgesamt die müssen sich auf dem
überschüssigen pharma markt bedienen ich
halte es für richtig dass eine regierung
angesichts der dramatischen darstellung
der lage von mai juni versucht ihre
bevölkerung insgesamt zu schützen indem
sie impfstoff gekauft und würde deswegen
der bundesregierung niemals ein
verhältnis noch die alte muss man da zu
sein einen vorwurf machen dafür dass sie
gehandelt hat wie sie gehandelt hat
trotzdem langfristig müssen wir uns
angucken ob wir dieses kartell der
pharmaindustrie in diesem punkt nicht
ein kleines bisschen erträglicher für
uns gestalten können gut ich habe hier
noch eine wunderbare
verschwörungstheorie die ich unbedingt
anbringen möchte und zwar geht eine mail
durchs internet die sagt die adjuvantien
also dieser verstärker in pandemrix was
eben hier in deutschland fast
ausschließlich eingesetzt wird lösen das
golfkriegssyndrom aus mit chronischer
müdigkeit und muskel räume für die these
wird daher geleitet weil auch die
soldaten im ersten golfkrieg mit einem
ähnlichen mittel geimpft worden sind und
die jetzt zu einem großen teil an dem
golfkriegssyndrom leiden was sagen sie
dazu gar nichts
man muss nicht auf jeden unsinn etwas
anderes drauf setzen wissen sie dieser
monokausale betrachtungsweise angesichts
dieser armen menschen die im golfkrieg
kämpfen mussten die gift waschen
ausgesetzt worden die den den die
menschen dieser brennenden quellen
ausgesetzt worden die in extremen
klimatischen verhältnissen unter extrem
schwierigen ernährungs und trinkt
bedingungen arbeiten mussten nun alles
monokausal auf diesen einen
impfstoffverstärker zurückzuführen das
sind einfach irre wissenschaftliche
ideen hier bitte ich einfach irgendwann
mal mit ein bisschen ruhe und ratio den
beweis anzutreten und nicht einfach
irgendwas ins netz zu stellen was nur
die leute verunsichern soll es gibt ja
auch die meinung es wird eigentlich viel
zu sehr übertrieben mit der
schweinegrippe die normale grippe wer
eigentlich viel gefährlicher da müssten
jeden tag dutzende tote gemeldet werden
stimmt das ist die normale also die
üblichen grippe erreger sind die viel
gefährlicher als die schweinegrippe ja
das ist so wir haben zurzeit eine lage
wo wir in den letzten jahren
pro winterhalbjahr zwischen 8 und 11
tausend menschen feststellen mussten die
an den folgen der grippe der klassischen
alten wintergrippe oder saisonalen
grippe wie wir sie denn gestorben sind
das sind etwa übrigens im winterhalbjahr
zwischen 60 und 100 am tag
ich sag es mal sehr einfach da hat kein
hahn danach gekräht
weil wir haben die grippe impfung
angeboten man muss immer dazu sagen die
meisten dieser menschen
sterben ja nicht an der grippe alleine
sondern die sind chronisch krank die
sind zum teil auch sehr betagt und dann
kommt eine grippe und jetzt sag ich mal
und ärztlich gibt ihnen den rest jetzt
gibt es aber einen zweiten effekt und
ich komme zurück auf die momentane
beobachtung bei der wintergrippe wir
stellen fest dass in diesem jahr bisher
die infektion mit der wintergrippe
offensichtlich sehr viel
zahlenmäßig geringer sind als in den
vergangenen jahren zu erwarten hier
findet ein konkurrenz effekt
offensichtlich stadt zwischen dem h1n1
virus und den normalen grippe viren und
interessanterweise
überwiegt das h1n1 derartig dass die
andere virus populationen sich in den
geschwächten menschen gar nicht
ausbreiten kann weil die erstmal mit
h1n1 kämpfen das heißt der
schweinegrippe virus ist bezüglich
seiner vermehrung ein äußerst
aggressiver virus weil alles andere
verdrängt
h1n1 in schweinen regel ist deswegen ja
auch so hoch ansteckend ein mensch der
in der u-bahn ordentlich puste und
schafft kann hundert andere anstecken
und deswegen gibt es übrigens über die
individuelle risiko nutzen abwägung
jedes bürgers ob er sich impfen lassen
wählen die man ihm nicht ersparen kann
und die auch legitim ist ist auch
legitim wenn jemand sagt ich will mich
nicht impfen lassen weil ich nunmehr
angst habe davor wir haben in
deutschland keine im 3 deswegen gibt es
darüber hinaus aber auch noch eine
bevölkerungs medizinische abwägung weil
nämlich jeder der das virus in
sicherheit zwei tage schon bevor er
überhaupt merkt dass das hat und krank
wird bereits andere menschen anstecken
kann und wenn nur jeder der es hat 100
andere ansteckt haben wir in kürzester
zeit eine explosionsartige vermehrung
des virus das ist hochansteckend hoch
kontaktlos deswegen auch in meinen augen
die völlig selbstverständliche forderung
dass sich medizinisches personal vor
allem diejenigen die mit
immungeschwächten patienten umgehen
impfen lassen sollte um nicht selber zur
quelle des virus für andere kranke
menschen zu sein die wesentlich
schlechter damit umgehen könnten dass
wir die gesund und kräftig sind eins
habe ich aber noch quecksilber soll drin
sein eine quecksilberverbindung und da
wird dann gefragt muss das denn sein
quecksilber sein schwert schweres
nervengift muss das denn sein dass das
ausgerechnet ich das beim arzt
verabreicht bekommen auch hier muss mal
wieder die mengen debatte vergleichen
damit es ist in der tat richtig dort ist
ein konservierungsstoff dritte hast
thiomersal der muster drin sein weil die
bundesregierung in ihrer unendlichen
weisheit den impfstoff in zehner
packungen gekauft hat das heißt da sind
immer zehn portionen in einer ampulle
dass sie die nicht einmal rausziehen
spritzen und wegwerfen verwenden können
sondern über einen tag halten müssen
muss ein konservierungsstoff drin sein
der heißt thiomersal und enthält
quecksilber quecksilber in
absolut dramatisch geringen
dimensionen wer regelmäßig ein- bis
zweimal in der woche seefisch ist nimmt
etwa dieselbe menge quecksilber auf in
der woche wie mit einer impfung mit
diesem stoff also ihre zusammenfassung
es gibt risiken die sind aber deutlich
geringer als die risiken der
schweinegrippe ist es richtig zusammen
absolut es gibt risiken bei dieser
impfung wie bei allen anderen impfungen
auch diese risiken sind deutlich
geringer als bei der schweinegrippe
das ist risiken gibt können sie alleine
daran sehen dass sämtliche bundesländer
inzwischen in ihre gesetze diese impfung
gegen h1n1 mit aufgenommen haben was
übrigens bedeutet dass nach der
rechtsordnung der bundesrepublik ein in
staden 1 wie eine anerkannte
berufskrankheit die eine anerkannte im
krankheit dann automatisch auch aus
staatlichen stellen reguliert wird und
auch die schadensersatzleistungen und
auch die folgekosten vom staat getragen
werden also auch noch mal ein
finanzieller vorteil der impfung die
schweinegrippe ist nicht ehrlich hat die
impfung ist versichert ja das wäre
allerdings sehr traurig wenn man sagen
der schaden ist versichert deswegen
sollte leute hingehen und nicht die
schweizer wollen ich sage mal
zuallererst jemand davon aus dass die
schäden nicht so sein werden wie sie von
manchen menschen befürchtet und
dargestellt werden die im staaten
debatte um die normale grippeimpfung
hatte es ja auch schon seit jahren nicht
mehr gegeben weil ganz offensichtlich
diesen impfgegnern die argumente
ausgegangen sind okay vielen dank